Speaker 1: My friends, once arrested and twice
impeached, failed.
Former President Donald Trump is about to
get arrested again, and this time it appears
federal charges are coming.
Trump's lawyers meeting with the Justice Department
yesterday, reportedly begging them, please.
Speaker 2: Please.
Speaker 1: With tears in their eyes, don't
charge Donald Trump.
CBS News reports Trump attorneys meet with
special counsel at Justice Department amid
Documents Investigation.
Great report by Robert Costa and others.
Attorneys representing Trump met with special
counsel Jack Smith and prosecutors at the
Justice Department 10 a.m. yesterday, according
to two people familiar with the matter.
This took place weeks after Trump's lawyers
requested a meeting with top federal law enforcement
officials.
The attorneys for Trump spent just under 2
hours inside the main justice building and
declined to comment as they left.
CBS News cameras captured Trump's legal team
walking in.
The former president's lawyers did not speak
as they entered a person familiar with the
meeting between the three attorneys and the
department said Merrick Garland was not there.
Two people familiar with the probe say Trump's
legal team is frustrated with how the Justice
Department has handled attorney client matters
in recent months and would likely raise concerns
during the meeting.
In particular, prosecutors discussions of
related issues in front of the grand jury.
Additional reporting from The Washington Post.
Trump lawyers Ask Justice Department not to
charge Trump in the classified documents case.
We now have reporting here about the reason
for the visit.
Quote, Attorneys for Donald Trump went to
the Justice Department Monday to make their
case.
The government should not charge the former
president in connection with his possession
of classified documents after leaving office,
as reported already in the other article.
They were there for 2 hours.
Merrick Garland wasn't there.
Justice Department has not commented.
This is an interesting paragraph.
While it is not uncommon in high profile cases
for defense lawyers to get such a meeting
with Justice Department officials towards
the end of an investigation, current and former
officials say such presentations rarely change
prosecutors minds to Trump.
Advisers briefed on Monday's meetings say
they continue to believe Smith will finalize
a charging decision in coming weeks.
The advisers say they are preparing for a
potential indictment of the former president.
The meeting did not change their expectations.
Donald Trump, by all reasonable reports, is
about to get arrested again, indicted again,
this time on federal charges.
These aren't even the only federal charges
Trump might be charged for.
Remember that there is a federal investigation
into Trump's mishandling of classified documents,
which we now know took place not only at Mar
a Lago, but also at Bedminster.
We now know Trump knew they were classified
based on an audio recording of Trump saying,
I have a document here, but I can't show it
to you because it's classified.
Which confirms Trump knew he had not actually
declassified the documents.
That's one slate of federal charges that could
be coming.
In addition, there are the potential charges
referred to the Justice Department by the
former House committee investigating the insurrectionist
Trump riots of January six, 2021.
That could lead to charges.
And in addition to that, Fannie Willis in
Georgia will be making a charging decision
on state level charges against Trump sometime
between July and September, when the next
grand jury is reconvened and those decisions
are going to be made.
We could see one, two or even three additional
arrests of the once arrested, twice impeached
former president just over the summer.
The question we are all now asking is whether
this will impact Trump, Trump's campaign for
the Republican candidacy and who of the other
people running for the Republican candidacy
for the Republican nomination stand to benefit
the most?
It seems it's DeSantis because he's the only
one in double digits at this point in terms
of the polling.
But we'll look at that a little more deeply,
probably Thursday, if not Friday.
In the meantime, Trump's reaction to news
that he will likely be arrested completely
and totally unhinged